Only half of American homes are equipped with basic emergency supplies...
...like a flashlight or bottled water.
To make sure your family is prepared for a weather-related disaster,...
...you'll need a well-stocked survival kit.
A complete survival kit should always have a self-winding radio,...
...a cell phone charger and enough food and water to last three to seven days.
You may even need baby supplies, medication or pet food.
You should also think about needs unique to your location.
Depending on your region, you might need extra blankets or bug spray.
Remember, in the event of a catastrophe,...
...ATMs and credit card readers are often down,...
...so be sure to keep some cash on hand.